I Dunno,
I,
I had,
uh,
I went to this facility in,
in San Diego is called,
um,
Dang,
why can't I remember,
oh,
a mindset.
And actually the UFC sent me there because I mean we have,
you saw though,
we have all of these things like,
um,
after fighting Amanda,
I got my head pounded for a good four minutes there.
Um,
I had a Tbi afterwards,
so that was like,
uh,
immediately lowered my estrogen,
lowered my da Da,
my testosterone and I'm hypo thyroid.
Like I will always be hyperthyroid now like I have.
Yeah.
And um,
you know,
still toughed it out.
So it was trying to do what I could to go and fight Ronda as soon as I did
afterwards.
And you know,
part of my game plan is don't get hit and which means like,
let's just dart outer and see what happens is,
you know,
so what,
that's what happens when you do that.
No,
Tbi is traumatic brain injury just in case there's someone who's listening to
this doesn't emerge down what we're talking about.
And then in the Rhonda fight,
if people don't know about that,
you just charged after and he got caught in an arm bar and like,
what was it?
Very quick
14,
it was 14 things,
but I did hit her with a knee.
I did throw her ass,
but she practiced a little Ninja move and comedy alarm and it was,
it was over,
you know.
But I mean even,
even her coaches were like,
I mean that's,
you did what you're supposed to do there.
And She just got you.
You know,
so,
um,
that would be an awesome fight to be able to revisit one day.
She even said we'd do it.
I mean,
who knows her career so open right now.
She will need to really doesn't need it.
I don't think she wants to.
I think,
I mean,
who knows,
you'd have to ask her,
but there's a lot of lessons to be learned.
And what happened to her in terms of like all of the distractions and Hollywood
came calling and there were scripts and talk about doing road house and there
was all this,
all this shit going on.
There was other than fighting and then it was also,
look,
the sport has evolved so rapidly in the women's,
women's MMA has gotten so high level so quickly and if he's,
I'm sure you saw a man does last fight with Raquel Pennington.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
I mean that was a fucking high level performance from her and five rounds,
super high cardio,
just put a beating down.
And Raquel Pennington,
he's one of the toughest girls in the world for sure.
Right?
I do like,
I mean I'm curious,
I was saying the same thing as the fights going.
Right.
And then I have,
uh,
some people in my ear next to me,
they're like,
well how long has it been since we're cal?
Fuck,
cause she didn't look her for like beefiest right.
She,
she looked a little tired.
She looked a little like not her typical and then it's like she's a year and a
half off herself.
Right.
Like right into a title fight,
which I have to say I'm a little bit envious of because when I beat Misha,
I,
when,
uh,
I was supposed to coach the ultimate fighter,
but that was all ultimately going to up in a title shot with Rhonda and I blew
my knee and my husband passed away and there was like a long moment of silence
in there.
And then when I was able to come back,
they made me return my title shot,
you know?
And so it was like,
wait,
oh,
we're doing that now.
Or just like we'll do
Penn on like what,
what attractive contenders are available.
Like what?
It looks good.
I agree.
Yeah.
I mean it was very young at that,
at that age or that at the time.
Right.
And in Bantam weight right now there's like,
there's no standout contender and Raquel had beaten some really good fighters
and she looked like the next in line.
And did she blow her knee out as well?
She has
not like,
oh,
I could be lying,
but I think she gotten like some accident with a four wheeler,
like rolled over and broke her leg or something.
I could like totally be making that up though.
She could have just twisted it walking down the street too,
so
vaguely remember some engine.
Yeah.